I know 4 squared is really 16, and 5 squared is really 25. I know 16 plus 25
makes 41. So, I have a total area 41. For the blue side, I have 20 plus 16 plus
20 plus 25. When I add all these areas together, I get an area of 81. This makes
sense because I know if I would have just combined the sides, I would have had
9, and then I would've squared it. 9 squared is 81. I know these two numbers are
not equal. We want to be really careful. Exponents cannot distribute over sums
or differences. We can't just say 4 plus 5 squared is the same thing as 4
squared plus 5 squared. This is a key concept that we will come back to later. I
just want to preview it for now and give you an idea of area models. This is
going to help us problem solve. Now, let's have you practice with some
exponents.